The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today we're
going to talk about bit
hacking, which is a topic that
has a long, long history in
computer science.
We'll only cover on a few
of the techniques.
So let's just get going.
So I want to swap
two integers.
So I think most of you would
know how to write a program to
swap two integers.
And it would look something
like this.
And mostly this is pseudocode.
I'm not going to be doing
declarations of types and
writing full code, in order to
make sure things get on slides
and so forth.
So what do you do?
You assign a temporary
to the value of x.
You then let x take
the value of y.
And then you let y take the
value of the temporary.
What could be simpler?
Well how about doing it
without a temporary?
So how do you swap two numbers
So here's one way.
So what's going on there?
So the carrot is an XOR,
exclusive or, OK?
So here's what's going on.
So let's do an example first.
So I have x and y.
I then let x be the
XOR of x and y.
So, as you see, that first bit
is the XOR of one and zero.
The second bit is the XOR of
zero and zero, which is zero.
The third bit is the
XOR of one and one.
That's zero.
And so forth throughout
the bits.
So then I let y be the
XOR of x and y.
And then, finally, I let x be
the XOR of x and y again.
And now, if you notice,
that number is the
same as that number.
And that number is the
Magic.
We're going to see a lot of
magic today actually.
OK?
We're going to see a lot of
magic today, no temporary.
Why does this work?
So the reason this works as a
great property of XOR is that
it's its own inverse.
So if you take x exclusive or
y, and you exclusive or that
with y, you get x.
If you were to exclusive or that
with x you would get y.
So that first step is basically
putting in here the
XOR of x and y so that when you
end up on the next step
computing the XOR of y
and this, you get x.
So now you've got x here.
And you've now got the original
x XORed with y here.
So to get back the value of
y you just XOR out the x.
So it swaps them.
Whose brain hurts?
You can study these later on.
But a pretty neat trick,
pretty neat trick.
Does it perform well?
Turns out not really.
And the other way is actually
a better way of doing it,
generally, with most compilers
and architectures.
And the reason is because the
other way of doing it you can
actually, essentially, pull two
things out of memory, one
into a temporary one--
and then stick them
back like this.
That's what the compiler
ends up doing.
Where as this one, it has
to wait for each step.
And so you don't get to exploit
instruction-level
parallelism.
Remember from last time
instruction-level parallelism
is the fact that a processor
can issue more than one
instruction at a given step.
And here, this sequence of
operations, each step has to
wait until the previous
one is computed
before it can execute.
So you get no instruction
parallelism in this.
So it's not particularly
high performing.
But there are other places
where we'll use
this kind of property.
But it's a neat bit hack,
swap two things
without using a temporary.
Now here's a real bit hack.
And a real useful one.
Finding the minimum of two
integers, x and y.
Gee whiz, let me just call a
sub routine or something.
So you might be tempted to write
something like this; if
x is less than y then
the result is x.
Otherwise, the result is y.
Seems pretty straightforward.
Or if you know a little bit more
c, you can write it with
this sort of cryptic if x is
less than y, then x else y.
So those are two equivalent
c ways of doing things.
So what's wrong with that?
Well nothing if you don't
mind slow code.
In fact, for something like
this the compiler actually
will optimize it to
deal with it.
But let me just point
out a couple things.
First of all, the processor
has within it a branch
prediction unit.
Whenever it comes to a branch
it guesses which way the
branch is going to go, and
proceeds to speculatively
execute along that path.
If it turns out to be wrong it
says, whoa, hold your horses,
got to go that way.
To do that, it empties the
processor pipeline.
And that takes, on the
machines we're
using, around 16 cycles.
So you don't want to have
branches that are
mis-predicted.
And, in particular, what
you want to look for in
conditional instructions, is
whether they're predictable.
So something that's almost all
the time branching the same
way, that's a predictable
branch.
The hardware is very smart
about figuring out how to
predict that, and will make
the right prediction.
And you won't pay any
performance penalty.
But if you have something where
you don't know which way
it goes, so in a code like this,
the architecture isn't
going to know.
If you just throw at it various
pairs of x and y it's
a 50/50 guess as to whether
it guesses right.
So half the time it's going to
predict the wrong thing.
So the compiler might
be smart enough.
But maybe not.
But you can be sure.
And here's a way
of being sure.
You write this code.
What is going on there?
So here we go.
We're taking x less than y,
and taking a minus sign.
Yikes, what's that do?
Well c represents the Boolean's
true and false with
the integers one and
zero, respectively.
So if you execute the operator
x less than y, as opposed to
doing a conditional based on x
bit less than y, it returns to
either a zero or a one,
depending upon whether it was
successful.
So when you take the negation
of that, this is
either zero or one.
It's either going to
be zero or minus 1.
And what is minus 1 in two's
complement arithmetic?
It's a word filled
all with ones.
So you either get a word all
filled with zeros or you get a
word all filled with ones.
So if x is less than y you get
a word all filled with one's.
So then what are you doing?
You're doing x XOR
y, and you're
ending it with all ones.
Well that's a noop to end
it with all ones.
To mask something-- if I do an
and of anything with one, I
get whatever the thing is.
So this expression ends up
evaluating to just x XOR y.
Great, then what?
I take y here and I XOR it, I
get back x because of that
inverse property of XOR.
So if x is less than y, then
r gets the value of x.
If x is greater or equal to
y then this expression
evaluates to zero.
And a word of zeroes ended with
x or y gives you a word
of zeroes because zero is
an annihilator for and.
Wherever you and with zero, it
doesn't matter what it is.
You get zero.
So therefore this just becomes
r equals y because
y XOR zero is y.
So pretty clever, is
this really better?
Seems like an awful
lot of operations.
Well the answer is yes it is,
because all of this goes on
within the processing unit
rather than with anything
having to do with memory.
It gets the values for x and y
to begin with and then it's
all instructions within
the processing unit.
Those typically take
one cycle.
And if there's any parallelism
in it the parallelism will be
able to execute even more than
one operation per cycle.
In fact, the machines we're
using have are six issue.
They can run six operation
simultaneously,
each taking a cycle.
So the difference between that
and going out to memory is
really quite considerable.
So everybody follow that?
Pretty cute trick, how
to make it go fast.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't the expression
that's tested,
doesn't it have to be
[? weighed for ?] the inner
expression before you take--
PROFESSOR: There's no--
this is a comparison.
This is operated like a--
so there's no compare
instruction there.
It's a CPU operation.
It's an arithmetic and logical
operation of the CPU that it
can do in one cycle,
is to compare.
The normal thing that you're
trying to do if you have an if
is you're trying to change
the program counter.
And that's what's costly.
Not the actual doing the test of
the branch, test of whether
x is less y.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Would you have to wait
for that to finish before
you can do the negation?
PROFESSOR: Yes you do.
So that's one cycle, two cycles,
we can add it up here,
three cycles.
This can be going
on in parallel.
So it's really only
two cycles total.
Three cycles, four cycles, so in
four cycles you can get the
minimum done.
The L1 cache in the architecture
we're using costs
you four cycles to fetch
something if you get a cache
hit in the L1 cache.
That's the cheapest memory
operation you
can do, is four cycles.
This computed the whole minimum
in four cycles.
Here's another one,
modular addition.
So sometimes you know something
that the compiler
doesn't know.
Like suppose that you know that
x is between zero and
some value n, and y is between
zero and some value n, and you
want to compute their sum.
So what is that the sum is going
to be less than what?
2n.
So normally a modular operation
is very expensive
because it involves a divide.
Now multiply is normally more
expensive than an ordinary ALU
operation that's just a bitwise
operation, like
addition, or XORing bitwise
XORs, or comparison,
or what have you.
Those are very cheap one
cycle operations.
Multiply is usually a many
cycle operation.
Divide is often implemented by
doing repeated multiplies
using any of a variety of
techniques, including Newton
techniques.
Sometimes there is a divider,
or a divide step.
But divide is, generally, in any
case more expensive, even
though it's doing operations
all within the processor.
So if you actually compute mod
using your percent thing.
This actually can be quite
expensive unless you're
dividing by a power of two.
If you mod a power of two
that's easy because the
processor, if knows it's a power
of two, if the compiler
knows it's a power of two,
it'll just do a masking
operation on the low order bits
to give you whatever the
remainder is, mod2 to the n.
But if you're not in that
situation, n may not be a
power of two, you still want
to do something modn, there
still are some tricks you can
play but the compiler won't-
this is one the compiler
generally won't play for you
because the compiler won't
know that these are
preconditions in your code.
By the way, one of the most
common things is just doing x
plus 1 modn.
Very, very common thing to be
doing, x plus 1 modn, where
you're wrapping around
in some index space.
Here's another way
you could do it.
So divide is expensive.
Here you could just say
z equals x plus y.
And then if z is less than n,
give z otherwise z minus n.
The problem with this
is that it's got an
unpredictable branch.
To execute this code, I could
have written it out with an if
statement, it's got to change
the program counter to execute
either this or this.
so not very fast because you
have an unpredictable branch.
And we already talked about that
has to empty the pipeline
if it's wrong in the guess.
So here's a way of doing
it which doesn't
have an explicit branch.
So we compute x plus y.
And now what we do is we look
at whether z is greater than
or equal to n.
And if it is, we're basically
going to take the negation.
So that if it's is greater or
equal to n, the negation here
is all ones, once again,
is minus 1.
And so this becomes n and-ed
with minus one.
That gives me n.
And so then I'll
take z minus n.
That's what I want
However, if this is z is less
than n, then this will
evaluate to zero.
Minus zero is zero.
And n and zero is zero.
And so I'll end up just
getting the x plus y.
So it's basically the same
trick with a couple of
twiddles on the minimum that we
saw on the previous foil.
Who's having fun?
Good.
As I said, we're going to
see lots of tricks,
magic tricks even.
Round up to a power of two.
This is a common thing that
you want to do here.
This, for example, goes on in
memory allocators, which we'll
talk about later
in the course.
So in a memory allocator,
somebody asks for a hunk of
storage of size 19, most memory
allocators want to give
out chunks that are powers of
two for reasons we will
discover later.
So you want to round up to the
next higher power of two.
So how do you do that?
So here's an example.
So what I do is I decrement n,
and then I update n or-ing it
with the left shift of n, and
then or-ing that with- sorry,
the right shift of n by one.
Then the right shift of n by
two, et cetera, et cetera.
So here's an example.
So here's my original number.
And what I want is to round it
up to the next power of two.
This is what I'm going to
end up with in the end.
See I've got the next
higher power of two?
Just one bit is on if I've
rounded up to the next higher
power of two.
So what do I do?
I basically decrement and then
I take this word and I shift
it by one to the right
and or it in.
And then I shift it by
two and or it in.
four and or it in.
And then, in fact, I shift
it by eight and or it in.
And I didn't do that.
And since this isn't a 64-bit
word I skipped the last two
instructions.
So what's going on when I'm
shifting and or-ing it in, by
one, by two, by four.
What's happening?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] this way
there's no number of ones
starting from the one.
PROFESSOR: Yeah basically, from
the most significant bit,
if you look at what's happening
with the most
significant bit, you're
shifting it by one.
Then you're shifting
it by two.
You're flooding the low
order bits with ones.
And because it's an or, as soon
as something gets set to
one, it stays a one.
So it doesn't matter what's
actually happening in the low
order bits.
The only bit that we care
about is this bit.
And it basically floods all of
the other bits with one.
And then, once I've flooded them
all with one I increment.
And that gives me a carry out to
this position and gives me
the next higher power.
So why did I decrement here,
and then increment there?
What's the decrement for?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So that you can flood
with one because you
want to get yourself back.
So you want to the
add the one--
PROFESSOR: But why did
I decrement first?
AUDIENCE: If you were not to
decrement, it would just flood
everything with ones.
PROFESSOR: Well here, if I
didn't decrement right here, I
would have gotten
the same result.
If you already have
a power of two.
If I already have a power of two
and I flood the low order
bits, then I increment,
I'll get the next
higher power of two.
So by subtracting one I make
sure that I'm handling that
base case when n is
a power of two.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does the [INAUDIBLE]
operate [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It actually, the
compiler is not going to care
in this case.
But it does make sure that it
doesn't bother to try to
return and keep around
the old value.
But it's smart enough to
not worry about that.
Yeah, I mean, some people like
post-fix decrementing, and
some people like pre-fix
decrementing and it doesn't
matter in most cases.
But sometimes doing it after--
there are situations where doing
it post-decrementing
costs you a cycle.
So everybody got
the idea here?
So basically round up
to a next power two.
How about computing a
mask of the least
significant one in a word?
So I want to mask which is the
power of two, the word that's
all zeros except for one in the
least significant one bit.
Any ideas how to do that?
This is a classic trick.
Everybody should know
this trick.
You take x and you and it with
its two's complement.
Take x and and it with it's
two's complement.
Why does that work?
So here's x, some value here.
The two's complement is the
one's complement plus one.
Right?
If you remember.
So one's complement just means
I compliment every bit.
The two's complement
is I compliment
every bit and add one.
So when I compliment every bit
and add one, basically I go
all the way to the least
significant bit and then I get
zeros after it.
So right up to there I get--
it's one's complement and then
it's basically- would have
been 0, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, plus 1.
The carrot pulls you
back up to there.
And so then when you and them
together, oh look at that.
There's our least significant
bit sitting there.
Pretty good one?
So so how do you find
an index of the bit?
So by an index I mean
this is bit 01234.
Well it turns out these days
many machines have a special
instruction to do that.
And so if you look around and
you find the right library
that calls that instruction, you
can use that instruction
pretty cheaply.
But there's still a lot of
machines, especially things
like Mobile machines, et cetera,
where they have a
depleted instruction set.
Where they have no instruction
to convert from a power of two
to essentially it's
log base two.
So LG is the notation
for log base two.
So how do you go about
doing that?
So what we're going to do is do
some magic to motivate the
solution to this.
So one way to do it is to
use the ESP instruction.
Are people familiar with
the ESP instruction?
What's that?
The stack [? order? ?]
No, no, that's BSP
on some things.
Or yeah, right, so in the
extended instruction set--
yeah, OK.
Yeah, so the ESP instruction;
Extra Sensory Perception.
And we have today the tremendous
magician Tautology
who is going to demonstrate the
theory behind finding the
index of the bit.
So please give a warm
hand for Tautology.
TAUTOLOGY: How about now?
Can everyone hear me?
So, as my good friend Professor
Leiserson has
mentioned, I am the
amazing Tautology.
And today I am going to show
you an amazing card trick
which will baffle your minds for
approximately five minutes
until he shows you
the next slide.
All right, but to do this I will
need five volunteers from
the audience.
PROFESSOR: Who can follow
instructions.
[LAUGHTER]
So who would like to volunteer
to participate in real magic?
Here we go, one, two, three,
four, only four?
We need one more.
So come on up and line up
along the front here.
We need one more, one
more volunteer.
One more volunteer, you
get extra points.
Remember participation is
part of your grade.
OK I'm going to cold call.
Here we go.
TAUTOLOGY: All right,
excellent.
Please cut this deck.
PROFESSOR: First you gotta
show it's a random deck.
TAUTOLOGY: All right, I will
first show you that's it's a
random deck.
PROFESSOR: It's only 32 cards.
It's only 32 cards.
So he pulled out some
of the other cards.
But they're in a pretty
random order there.
So we want to give everybody a
chance to shuffle the deck
here by doing a cut.
Look at it, but don't show
it to Tautology.
Why don't you go around
the back so that the
class can see the cards?
So hide your cards while
he runs around behind.
And then turn them around so
that the class can see what
the cards are.
TAUTOLOGY: All right, are you
guys ready to turn around?
Cool, excellent.
PROFESSOR: I'm not going
to look at them either.
There are no dupes.
This is all done by ESP.
TAUTOLOGY: All right, now-
PROFESSOR: Why don't you
come over here where
you can see the class?
TAUTOLOGY: Hello everybody.
I'm going to tell you what is
on those five cards, which I
have not seen.
Behold I have not seen them.
OK, are you guys ready?
PROFESSOR: Now you've got
to think about it.
You've got to think hard about
what your card is.
If you're not sure
you can check.
But you've got to think real
hard about what your card is.
TAUTOLOGY: Okay.
PROFESSOR: Are you guys
thinking hard?
I think you need some
technological assistance.
TAUTOLOGY: I could use some
PROFESSOR: There we go.
This is our brain amplifier.
It amplifies the brain waves
coming from you.
OK, give it a go.
TAUTOLOGY: Hang on,
is this thing on?
There we go.
Now it's on.
OK, here I go.
All right guys I'm having
kind of an off day.
So I'm going to need a
little bit of help.
Can you guys just raise
your hand if you're
holding a red card?
So that's a red?
PROFESSOR: Red, red,
black, red.
They did it right, right?
TAUTOLOGY: Now let me
give this a shot.
So red, black, red, red, red.
PROFESSOR: No, red, red - yes
OK you do it your way.
TAUTOLOGY: Now, now
I might be wrong.
But I think- am I seeing a
diamond with a seven on it?
Is that what I'm seeing?
PROFESSOR: Oh!
How impressive is that?
TAUTOLOGY: OK, one
down, four to go.
What else am I seeing?
I believe I am seeing.
You're going to have to think
about this card pretty hard.
I'm having an off day.
So I think I'm seeing
a spade, with a six.
Thank you for your honesty.
Thank you.
It does mean a lot to me.
All right, so I'm seeing a-
now what am I seeing now?
What could this be?
It's some kind of a heart.
I think, just maybe, it
has a value of five.
PROFESSOR: Oh!
Three in a row!
I don't think he's doing
this at random.
There must be ESP
at work here.
TAUTOLOGY: Clearly.
It's all the hat to be honest.
It's all the technology, just
the latest technology.
All right, so-
PROFESSOR: It gets
harder as we go.
TAUTOLOGY: It does get
But, what is this?
do I- I think- no it can't
be- can it be?
The three of hearts?
It's the three of hearts!
My old nemesis the
three of hearts.
OK just one more card.
[LAUGHTER]
Did you just swap cards?
I think I just watched
you swap you cards.
Well I'm just going
for in the set-
PROFESSOR: And they did it
without a temporary notice.
They must have xor-ed them
together or something.
TAUTOLOGY: So the last card,
which may or may not be in the
last person's hands.
Let me see if I can see it.
What could it be?
No, no!
No, anything, not
the- not that!
Not the 6 of diamonds!
PROFESSOR: All right,
five out of five!
Thank you, thank you.
OK guys go back to your seats.
So that was a pretty
easy trick, right?
TAUTOLOGY: Yeah, pretty easy.
PROFESSOR: So how
does it work?
What's the basic
idea behind it?
So key thing is how many bits
of information did he get?
Five bits of information.
And there were how many
cards in the deck?
Thirty-two.
So the pattern of the five bits,
of which cards were read
let him know where in the cyclic
sequence of cards he
was, right?
Because the cards really
weren't random.
They just looked random.
And so five bits is enough.
But that means that every the
sequence of five cards in that
deck, as you rotate it
around, has to have a
different bit pattern.
So does anybody know a name
for that property?
A circular sequence that
has that property?
The property is that if
you- well, let's see.
Maybe I have it up here.
So here's our magic code,
which is going to
compute the log of x.
And it's using what's called
a De Bruijn sequence.
So let's come back to the
magic trick in a minute.
And let's look to see
how we compute this.
And then we'll understand
how both work.
There's a magic number here
called De Bruijn.
De Bruijn was a Dutch
mathematician.
And then there's this funny
conversion table.
And to find the log of x, where
x is a power of two, I
multiply x by this magic
number here.
Right shifted 58 places.
This is keeping how many bits
after the multiply here?
Six bits because it's
a 64-bit word.
And then looking it
up in this table.
So let's take a look at
what's going on there.
So a De Bruijn sequence, s, of
length 2 to the k, is a cyclic
zero one sequence, such that
each of the two to the zero
one strings of length k occurs
exactly once as a
substring of s.
That's a mouthful.
Let's do an example, smaller.
So for example k equals 3.
So here's a sequence, 0, 0,
0, 1, 1, 1, 0, 1, base 2.
If I look at the first three
bits it's 0, 0, 0.
The second three bits
is 0, 0, 1.
And notice that as I go through
here every sequence,
and these are wrapping around
the end, taking the last bit
and then the first
two of the end.
Every one of these gives you
an index of every different
bit pattern of length 3.
So these came up because people
played with those
keypads where you have to enter
a combination, right?
And if you have a keypad
and you want to enter a
combination- let's say the
keypad has only two numbers on
it, 0 and 1.
And you have to hit the right
sequence of k numbers.
So the naive way of doing it
would be to say well let's try
0,0,0,0,0,0,0.
Then let's try 0,0,0,0,0,0,1,
then 0,0,0,0,0,1,0.
So what that'll do is you'll
have to go through 2 to the k
numbers, each of which is k bits
long, for k times 2 to
the k punches in order to be
sure that you've hit every
number to open the lock.
The De Bruijn sequence takes
it from k times 2 to the k
down to 2 to the k.
Still exponential in k, but
there's k at the front because
it's making it so that each
sequence that you have nests
into the previous one.
And that's basically what's
going on here.
Every sequence of length
3 exists in
the De Bruijn sequence.
And so this one here is a De
Bruijn sequence of length 64
as it turns out.
And what we had in the magic
trick was a De Bruijn sequence
of length 32.
So that when you cut the cards
and you looked at the first
five cards that was a unique
pattern of reds and blacks.
It told you where you were in
the rotation of the sequence.
And then there's a little bit
of cleverness to how it is
that you translate
that into cards.
Because remembering 32 cards,
and what their sequence was,
and so forth, that's
pretty hard.
But it turns out you
can just do an
encoding of the five bits.
Two of the bits encode
the suit.
So the high order bit encodes
the suit, the two bits encode
the suit, and then the last
three bits tell what the
number is, 1 through 8.
So that's how that worked.
It wasn't really magic
after all.
Who's surprised?
So how can we use this in
this particular code?
So for this, basically
the convert
table does the following.
It says, well, if you've got
zero, the offset, the shift of
this amount here, is zero.
And if you've got one, then
the shift is one.
And if you have a six-
where's six in here?
Sorry if I have a two here,
then that's going
to be that I'm six.
So this table is inverting
this number.
Do people see the relationship
there?
So if I know what the pattern is
I can do a look up and tell
how much did I shift by?
If I am shifting by a
given amount there,
or circularly shifting.
So here's the way
that code works.
Let's say we've got a number
like 2 to the fourth that I'm
trying to figure out what
the exponent is.
It's always a power of 2.
So I'm looking at 2 to
the fourth and I
want to extract 4.
But all I have is the mask
that's 16, which
has the one bit on.
What I do is I multiply this
number, the De Bruijn sequence
number, by 16.
Well what happens when you
multiply by a power of 2?
It shifts it by 4 bits.
So it's shifted the
bits by 4 bits.
And now if I right shift
it by 8 minus 3, I
capture the top 3 bits.
In this case, 1, 1,
0, which is 6.
Then I convert 6.
It says I had a shift of 4.
And just with 64 bits it's a
longer De Bruijn sequence.
So it's performance is limited
by the fact that you have to
do a multiply and
a table look up.
But it's generally fairly
competitive for many machines
that do not actually have a log
base 2 of a power of 2.
These days machine instructions
are getting-
there are instructions that
will do that in a single
instruction for you.
But if you don't happen to have
one on your architecture
and need to do this fast
this is a reasonably
fast way to do it.
Even with a table look
up and the thing.
The other way of doing it, of
course, would be to shift by
one, shift by one, shift by one,
until you get the one.
And there's some other
techniques as well
that you can use.
You can do divide and conquer in
a binary way, where you do
binary search for where the
bit is, by shifting and so
forth, and hone in.
But the problem with those
techniques, the binary search
in particular, is what?
If I try to binary search
to find a bit what's
that going to be?
Yeah, branching.
You're going to have
unpredictable branches.
And each of those will
cost you 16 cycles.
And so with a 64-bit word you've
got 16 cycles times six
bits that you're trying to
decode, times however many
instructions it actually
takes you.
It adds up to a lot of cycles.
But that can sometimes
be an effective way
of doing it as well.
And there are other ways.
You can look byte by byte.
There are a variety of
other techniques.
Anyway, but this
is a cute one.
Here's another one,
population count.
Count up the number of
one bits in a word.
So here's one way of doing it.
I start out r at zero.
And I keep incrementing r.
And what I do is I quit
when x is zero.
And what I do is I do that
trick of x, ending it
with x minus 1.
Which does what?
Eliminates the low order bit,
that's one, the low order one.
So basically I go through and
I just kick out one of the
ones, kick out another one of
the ones, kick out another one
of the ones, until I'm done.
This has a branch in it.
But in some sense it's a
predictable branch because
almost all the time you're
going through the loop.
However, it has downside, which
is that suppose you're
given minus 1.
Then you have to do 64
iterations of this loop before
you can get your final answer.
And so that's a lot of
iterations to do.
So here's what's going
on in your loop.
Here's x.
Here's x minus 1.
And now if I and them it's
very similar to the other
trick that I taught you.
You and them, notice you have
the same number you started
with except it's missing
the one low order bit.
So this is fast if the
population count is small.
If you know there's only a
couple of its on in the word,
then this can be a pretty
effective technique.
But in the worst case it's going
to take it's going to be
proportional to the number
of bits in the word.
Because you're only getting
rid of one bit at a time.
But it's better, in some sense,
than looking one bit at
a time because you have the off
chance that the number of
one bits will be sparse.
Whereas if you just looked at
the low order bit, then the
next bit, then the next bit,
that would definitely take you
worst case every single time.
Here's another way to do it.
It's a table look up.
So you have to pay, but if
you're doing this a lot maybe
all of this is an L1 so the
table look up only costs you
four cycles if it's
an L1 cache.
So what is this sequence?
This tells for any given byte,
so there's 256 values, how
many ones are in the world.
So zero has zero one bits.
One has one one bit.
Two has one one bit, three
has two one bits.
Four has one one bit, five has
two, six has two, seven has
three, eight has
one, et cetera.
So that's this table.
I didn't fill out the
rest of the table.
And now what you're doing in
this loop is you're basically
taking a look at
the value of x.
You're right shifting it and
then your indexing, masking
with the low order byte.
So you may ask the
low order byte.
You add that to the count by
doing a look up, which
hopefully only takes you four
cycles if the table is in L1.
And then just run around this
loop until you've got no more
things in your word.
So how many are in byte one, how
many are in byte two, how
many are in byte three,
and so forth.
For things that use table look
up you have to be careful
because if you have a great big
table why not look up two
bytes at a time?
Well two bytes is
65,000 entries.
So why not look up four
bytes at a time?
Four bytes is four
billion entries.
At that point you're going out
to memory and starting to
consume a lot of space.
So here's some common numbers.
These are sort of approximate.
But generally if you're doing
operations on registers, one
cycles, and plus you can issue
six per core, per cycle.
So L1 cache is going to cost
you around four cycles, L2
cache about 10, L3 about
50, and D RAM
about 150 to 200 cycles.
When you access these you get,
in fact, generally for all
these, you tend to get
a 64 byte cache line.
So you're getting
more than one.
But if what you're doing is
random access in a table it
doesn't help that all those
other bytes are coming in.
Population count three using
parallel, divide, and conquer.
Here's the clever one.
Here's the code.
It's all register operations
basically.
So it's creating some masks.
So let's just take a look
at what does this first
instruction do?
It's taking minus one.
It's shifting it left 32 bits.
So that gives all ones in the
higher order half of the word,
and all zeros in
the lower half.
And then it's xor-ing
it with minus one.
But with all minus ones.
So that gives you a mask
of ones in the low
order half of the word.
Yeah question?
AUDIENCE: Why don't you just do
negative one right shifted.
Isn't there a type of-
PROFESSOR: Yeah you
can do that.
I was trying to be
consistent here.
And, in fact, for these first
two operations there are
actually more clever ways of
doing this that take fewer
operations.
AUDIENCE: Isn't there a right
shift operator that
[? pulls some ?] zeros
in the top level?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so there's
logical versus arithmetic
right shift.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
But then I wouldn't have
the pattern that
I'm setting up here.
So yes, in fact, if you want to
play with it yourself you
can optimize these first
two statements.
They don't need to be as
complicated as this one.
But basically what you're doing
in every step is your
shifting it over, half
the word, xor-ing it.
And then the second one is you
get a block of 16 bits of
zeros, 16 ones, 16
zeros, 16 ones.
The next one you get a block of
eight zeros, eight one's,
eight zeros, eight ones.
And so basically you're
generating masks for that.
So by the time you get down to
the last one you're having
every other bit is zero.
You're alternating
zeros and ones.
And then, basically-
well let me not go
through the code here.
Let me show with an example.
The main thing to observe is
that it takes log n time where
n is the word length
to do this.
So here's population count on
32 bits, same kind of thing.
So here's the idea.
We extract every other bit
for the two words.
So you saw how I extracted
that right?
So we extract.
So I can do that with
a mask and a shift.
And then I add them together.
So just so we can see what's
being added here.
And when I add them together the
largest value I'm going to
have in any one of these
things is what?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: And [? that, ?]
fortunately, fits in two bits.
So we can get off the ground.
So now every two bits has
the sum of the two
bits that were there.
The bits that I'm not showing
are all zeros because it's
done 64 bit words.
The bits I'm showing
are all zeros.
So now what do we do?
We mask and shift and take off
every two pairs of bits and
then add them together.
So now this guy is saying
there's four bit that were
originally in the
word that began.
This one says there are two bits
in that range, one bit,
one bit, two bits, three bits,
two bits, two bits.
So we do it again.
Add it together.
And we just keep going.
And then finally we add
them all together.
It says there are 17 ones in
the word, which there were.
I should have probably left the
word up there or something
so we could verify that.
But Yeah there are 17 ones.
So everybody see it's parallel,
divide, and conquer
because you're adding many
words, many sub-pieces pieces
of the word [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And the key thing is to make
it so that no carries are
propagating out of
their range.
But the numbers are just getting
smaller and smaller.
When you're done you're only
going to have six bits here
that are significant anyway.
All of these will be zeros.
Is that cool?
So there's a 17, yeah.
Here's a problem for which
bit representations
are a lot of fun.
Last year we gave this as
a problem to students.
This year we're giving you a
different problem so that lets
me lecture on it.
So many people are probably
familiar with this problem.
It's an old chess nut.
But basically the queen's
problems is to place n queens
on an n by n chess board so that
no queen attacks another.
So there are no two Queens in
any row, column, or diagonal.
So queen's kind of
move like this.
It's got to be clear.
If I did that around any one
of these guys they wouldn't
hit anybody else.
In fact, this arrangement here
is, I think, one of the few
symmetric ones.
Maybe it's the only
symmetric one.
It's radially symmetric.
Most of them are
more scattered.
So the question is how do you
find such a thing, or count
the number of solutions,
is another
popular one, et cetera.
A popular strategy for this is
called backtracking search.
And we're going to have in
your homework a different
backtracking search.
And the idea is you just simply
try to place the queens
row by row.
So, for example, we start out
with the first row, row zero,
and we place a queen.
Then we go to the next row.
And we try to see if a queen
works on that square, nope,
nope, yes it works there.
Now we go on to the next row.
So this is making progress.
We're placing queens.
We're going to more rows.
We're going to get to the
end of the rows, right?
So we keep- yep, we found it.
And we keep going.
This is easy.
Found it right after
two there.
That's pretty good.
Found it there.
Look, we're making
great progress.
Doesn't go there, doesn't go
there, doesn't go there,
doesn't go there, oops
doesn't go anywhere.
So what do we do?
We backtrack.
We say, gee, if it didn't fit
in any those but it had
nothing to do with the placement
there, it's the
fault of the guy who
came before me.
So that position is not a valid
position, at least with
that prefix.
So we continue with him.
Aha, we found another
place for him.
So then we try this one.
Oops this doesn't look good,
aha, got to backtrack.
Whoops that's the last
one in the row, got
to backtrack again.
So that means that guy
can't go there.
Found a place, now we get
to go forward, hooray.
And you keep going on.
So you backtrack, et cetera,
until you finally
find a place for them.
So the backtracking search
is pretty interesting.
But the question is how do you
represent it so that it can go
really fast.
So here's some ideas.
The first idea you might come up
with is to use an array of
n squared bytes, where you put a
value in the byte if there's
a queen there.
You should, at this point,
figure out that, gee all I
have to know is whether a
queen is there or not.
So why should I keep a byte?
Why not just keep a bit?
That'll be smaller and have
a smaller representing.
So let's keep n squared bits.
Well let's see.
If I'm only putting a queen in
one place in every row I never
have to have more than one
bit set in any row.
So why not just say the column
number in the row that I'm in?
So rather than using an array of
n bits for every row let me
just use an index of a byte to
say which row that one queen
is in because there can't be any
other Queens in that row
in a legal configuration.
So that's actually
more clever.
And that's the way most
people code it.
But we're going to look at a
solution that was originally
due to Edsger Dijkstra of using
three bit vectors to
represent the board.
And the idea is we want to make
things go- we're going to
use three bit vectors that
are relatively small.
So it turns out the
n queens is an
exponential search problem.
And so you really can't run n
queens on 128 by 128 board.
You can run that if you're
interested in one solution.
You can't count up how
many solutions.
And if you go to Wikipedia and
look at n Queens they will
tell you what all the latest
records are for who has
computed how many solutions
there are on an n by n board
for n up to some rather
small number.
So it's a way to get your name
on the web, which, as you
know, is very difficult to do.
So let's see this three
bit vector trick.
So the idea of the bit vector
trick is that, for any partial
placement, rather than
representing where the queens
are on the board, what I really
care about is which
columns have been knocked out.
So, therefore, what I'll do is
I'll store a one if there's a
queen in that column and a zero
if I don't have a queen
in that column.
So the point is I can keep the
whole representation of the
column mask in a word that just
tells me whether I have
ones or zeros in a column.
Now how do I know whether it's
safe to place a queen in a
given column?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How do I know, if
I try to place a queen say,
here, how do I know whether
that's OK or not?
Suppose that my program
wants to try to put a
queen in this space.
It can't because there's
something here.
It's just some operations on
words, which we will see here.
So placing a queen in column
c is not safe if
this down were here.
When I and it with one shifted
left by the number of columns
so that I have the position of
the queen in the column if
that's non-zero because
it means somebody
else is in that column.
If it's in a new column when I
do the and I'll get all zeros.
Everybody follow that?
So testing columnists, whether
it's safe to put it in a given
column, from the column attack
we can do that really, really
efficiently, right?
These are all going to
be in registers.
No memory operations, no table
look ups, no L1 caches, all
right in registers.
Well what do we do about
the diagonals?
So for the diagonals we can
also use a bit vector
representation for
each diagonal.
Where I look to see if there's
a number along this diagonal,
and if there is a queen
then it's a one.
And if there isn't a queen on
the diagonal it's zero.
There are more diagonals then
there are columns, right?
So I have a longer bit vector
representation.
I have to represent that.
But I can still do that in one
computer word for things of
different size, or even for
things that are pretty good
size two computer words would
be, certainly, ample.
So now how do I tell whether
or not a queen placed on a
given square can legally
be placed there?
So it turns out it's not safe to
place it if when I take my
writer ray, and I take n minus r
plus c, and left shift it by
that amount, and that's
non-zero.
So here I'm indexing rows and
columns from the upper left
hand corner.
And so, basically, you're trying
to say is, for a given
square, notice that if I
increase the row, that's this
way, I get to the same- of if
I'm increasing the row, I'm
decreasing the diagonal
that I'm on.
But if I'm increasing the column
I'm increasing the
diagonal I'm on.
So that's it's basically
a difference here.
And then you just normalize it
and with essentially very,
very few operations I can
tell whether there's a
conflict in a column.
Of course, for both this and
the other one, if I need to
set it now that's pretty
simple also.
I just take this and
or it with right.
If my test is good, I just take
this, or it with right,
and now that's my new right.
And left is similar.
So, once again, we have these
guys going this way, placing a
queen in row r.
And column c is not safe if-
and now I just look at row
plus column because these
diagonals increase with both
row and column.
You're increasing the diagonal
for both row and column.
And so I'm not going to
go through all the
details of the code.
But you can see that with this
representation, literally, the
inner loop of your program,
which is testing whether
queens fit on boards and then
setting them if they do, you
can do with just three words
and a few operations.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Can you mask the three
bits together and check
if one position is taken up?
You'd have to do some creative
stuff with lining up the row
and column vectors with
the diagonals, but-
PROFESSOR: So typically
here you're looking at
both row and column.
So you're adding them, whereas
on the previous one you were
subtracting.
And then the first one you
didn't even care about what
the column was.
So I'm not sure I would know
how to combine those.
It's conceivable you
could do it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
column vector, you could add
the two together and find
specific positions
that are free.
PROFESSOR: Yeah so you could
also do a generation that says
here are the ones that are free
and then use things like
the least significant bit trick
to pull out what is the
positions I should
bother to check.
So here I can test
that it's safe.
But I could also generate using
similar tricks, which is
what you're saying, generate all
of the bit positions on a
given row where it would
be safe to put a queen.
Yep, yep, good.
So fast programs use
this technique.
So you see that there's a lot
of cleverness in these kinds
of techniques.
So there are a whole bunch of
other bit hacking techniques.
One really good resource
for it is this webpage.
And of course I'll put this up
on the- called bit twiddling
hacks, where he's compiled-
there's a lot of people that
have worked on different
bit twiddling hacks.
And he's done a very good job
of compiling what he thinks
are the best code sequences for
a whole bunch of things,
including things like reversing
the bits in a word.
If you think about it that
could be kind of tricky.
Actually turns out
to be relevant to
your homework as well.
So on your homework, so lab
one will be- it's posted I
gather, right?
It'll be posted shortly.
We have you trying to take
advantage of some of these bit
tricks in a couple of warm
up exercises and then a
backtracking search algorithm.
And so I think you'll find
it's a lot of fun.
You'll learn a lot about all the
kinds of tricks you can do
to make stuff go fast by using
register operations locally,
and using good representations
for your storage.
Yes, also, announcement.
Tonight, at 7 o'clock, in 32,
144, there is a primer on c.
So if you want to brush up on
your c or if you want to learn
c, this is a good time to go.
There's a lot of good nuggets
of wisdom coming out for c.
OK, thanks very much.
See you Thursday.